hi my name is NI Nash bets and I feel
very sexy about being Conan O'Brien's
friend yes this is the best answer I've
been listening to years and years of
people say I feel you know confused I
feel less than enthused but you nailed
it very sexy by the way you look amazing
thank you you look incredible thank you
and you always do you came on my show
many times you always always look
absolutely Divine well see and that's
part of why I feel sexy because I have
to pull up for you you know you know I'm
Team Coco like I'm in it I'm all the way
in it you're all the way in I'm all the
way I've never been all the way in
anything yeah I'm all the way in it so
when I know when I pull up for you I
have to present that is fantastic hence
I feel sexy yeah and look at me I just
look like I sort of work at the library
and not even they won't even let me near
the books I'm doing enough today for the
both of us okay you I got it I got
amazing incredible you know I was just
telling you that I was uh just before I
sat down to talk to you minutes ago I
was talking to a bunch of students who
came by and they're all studying
Communications and they wanted to know
you know give us some advice about the
business and I talked to them for a
while and the first thing you said when
I came in is this what did you tell them
did you tell them I said did you tell
them the truth now you tell us what the
truth is oh my goodness if you want to
you know to prepare you for Show
Business make sure you buy a
big uh
flat of Top Ramen yeah ramen noodles
because that I didn't say I lived on
chicken flavored ramen noodles and I
could make a tuna fish sandwich oh yeah
that's what I lived off of for years
that's what I'm trying to that's why you
got to tell the kids right I didn't say
that you got to tell them to always make
sure they have Advil or some sort of
pain reliev because you get a sore back
sleeping on different couches yes you
you know you got to tell them these
things yeah you got to tell them that
they will talk about you right in front
of your face in an audition like you're
not even standing there this happened to
me I'm literally in an audition and I
and the and the one woman says to the
guy sitting next to it she has a cute
face do you think she could lose weight
and I was like I can hear you you're
right there I'm right here first of all
that experience you do get dehumanized I
I feel you know I was always a writer I
never went just the the pure acting
route for good reason and I think I
saved America some bad acting but but
but but I see how you have to go they'll
bring in 9,000 people for one role and
they read you and they probably stop
seeing you as a person and more as just
like this is a commodity can we use this
person can we not and they Shuffle you
through and that does such a number on
people's egos for me I have to say that
and this is another thing you could tell
the kids that I've always known that
there is a difference between the call
on your life and a hobby those are two
different things you're going to show up
differently cuz when I knew that this
was you know my plan a and my plan B was
to make my plan a work when I walked
into that room if they did not choose me
I had no problem saying I feel so sorry
for you and I man it with my whole chest
that's great that's great you know what
I mean cuz you don't know I'm going be
the thing you'll see watch and see yeah
you know what I mean so so where did you
get that where do you get that
confidence cuz a lot of people would
kill to have that confidence I get that
confidence if I've had a lot to drink oh
oh boy no really just a lot to drink I
feel like it's if you you're missing out
on this and my wife says shut
up you know I am it she's like you're
really not you know but that's how I
feel if I've if I've had some kind of
substance well I would probably have to
say very early on I just chose to
believe the Manu Factor I'm like that's
you know what I mean when I pray and I
understand what my marching orders are
what I sense and my spirit is for me and
I just move forward with Reckless
abandon I don't I don't even think about
it not happening and when people don't
see it I I'm like oh okay
you you know even when I even from when
I met Ed Asner as a kid on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame I told him I was like I
know you don't know me my name is NI I'm
going to get a star right here one day
and he was like yeah kids scr and I he
put a cigar out on your head basically
and I was screaming as he was walking
away remember my name you know so I
didn't have a doubt about it but then
you got a star and I invited him to come
you seriously did I invited him to come
he sent me a letter and said I reminded
him of our
conversation he said said I'm glad you
didn't let a crotchy old man keep you
from your dream God and he said of
course I know your name and he drew a
star and he wrote my name in it and he
said he could not come but the day
before my ceremony I got a call and he
said I'll be there wow and he came
that's amazing yeah he came to my my
star ceremony it's funny because you
have to have there's no other word than
some sort of divine
voice in you that tells you this is
going to this is going to work you know
yes and even though you have it it
doesn't mean you don't have days tell
the kids this too get you some knee pads
cuz you going to be crawling across that
floor holling and crying because there
are some things you want so bad oh yeah
and even though you know everything is
divinely ordered in your Humanity we
just want what we want when when we want
it you know and how we want it so I I've
had days like that you know where people
didn't see see me like I saw myself
people thought I was a onetick pony for
a long time they're like oh no you do
comedy we know what you do and I'm like
I can do more than that you you know the
adage people who can make you laugh can
make you cry the reverse is not always
true right you know what I mean your
best dramatic actors you're probably
never going to see on a comedy and you
know a multi cam coming this fall you're
not you're you're just not but somebody
who can make you laugh has the bandwidth
has the agency has the depth to also
bring you to tears and I was like give
me a chance and for a long time they
said no and then finally I got a chance
and now I'm doing so much drama I think
people forgot I'm funny I'm like oh Lord
Hy write me a
[Laughter]
script